choix en france c'est un événement
théâtral depuis mardi et pour une
soixantaine de représentations robert
hossein joue dans huis clos de sartre au
théâtre marigny théâtre qu'il dirige
depuis deux ans une pièce qu'il a mise
en scène robert hossein bonsoir ça fait
beaucoup en selon bon jeu avec les
années j'essaie de gagner le plus tôt
possible pour tenter de réaliser en
cause certaines choses avec mes
camarades
est ce que vous trouvez du plaisir à
revenir sur scène est ce que vous devez
trouver du plaisir à être finalement
dans le rôle de deux de ses acteurs que
vous dirigez au quotidien vous êtes
comme maintenant oui c'est à dire que je
ne joue pas souvent fréquemment joutes
observé cias la branche du souvent le
génie c'est 18 heures de travail par
jour mais le talent c'est d'en trouver
aux autres et à partir de ce moment là
je joue huis clos d'abord un hommage à
sartre ensuite ya longtemps que je ne
suis pas monté sur scène comme comédien
donc j'ai eu le trac d' usage c'est
normal comme les esprits mais comment
est ce que vous vous trouvez du talent
en tant qu'acteur non absolument pas je
ne trouve ni talent nico backton et
comme rien du tout je sais je suis pas
du tout formaté excusez moi je crois
beaucoup je voulais vous faire ce
travail
et puis au travail et à l'équipe et
ensuite on a terminé donc juste avait
partie tournait d'ailleurs est il
il a terminé crime et châtiment dimanche
dernier nous avons commencé
qu'avant-hier après une tournée à
l'étranger en france des huit clos de
sartre à qui je voulais rendre un
hommage une pièce complètement
intemporel visionnaire et complètement
mais alors complètement aujourd'hui
d'actualité
alors qu'est-ce qui a d'actualité dans
cet homme que vous jouez gard fin avec
ses deux femmes qui se retrouvent en
enfer il n'y a pas d'échappatoire vous
êtes là pour l'éternité qu'est ce qu'il
y a 2 d'éternel justement la violence le
cynisme l'affrontement terrible avec des
gens qui essaient se disculper qui
essaient de se justifier auprès des
options même comme idée des choses
absolument terrifiante et ils essaient
chacun d'eux d'essayer de trouver chez
l'autre regarde plus indulgent à une
compréhension
alors qu'eux-mêmes et de temps en temps
ils ces tentatives semblent aboutir au
plus tard ou si la déflagration ça peu à
l'image de notre vie sartre a dit cette
phrase qui est devenu très célèbre
l'enfer c'est les autres
c'est un qui sont dans ce paradis c'est
simplement que nous sommes nous vivons
toujours avec le regard des autres
positionne ce qui des fois nous rend
complètement quelque part à leurs
pigeons n'osent pas nous assumer nous
mêmes une autre vie et nous et nos
parcours parce qu'on a toujours sur nous
on tient tout en compte du regard que
pose les autres surtout ce qu'on tente
de faire nous mêmes
alors on va regarder un extrait de la
pièce le regard des stèles une jeune
femme blonde une bourgeoise coquette qui
tentent de vous séduire que tu as commis
de graves exactions et qui a commis deux
grandes exactions on la regarde dans cet
extrait bien alors
mon histoire d'accord qui ferait la fin
je me suis trouvée là-bas chez moi la
tension n'est rien pour te plaire moi je
ne suis pas insinuer et je suis navré je
mange pas le cambouis se rendrait comme
tu es et s en serait peut-être
j'en veux pas ce que je serais dit c'est
la boj et gilles dodge afférentes nickel
à faire mais ça ne m'intéresserait pas
ce massif et surtout canapé j'attendrai
que tu tiennes
ap l'avant ap le mans il n'est même pas
bon mais n'a pas dit où il n'a pas d'eau
rien et entamer un temps atteint comme
seconde je t'aide à l'hommage que je
pourrai mais ce sera pas beaucoup
d'argent suivant avec toi je te dirai
pas non mais c'était ma part c'est pas
parce que tu aimerais pas à ce que je te
connais trop c'était une désir
estelle garcin et vous gardez le fasse
mais finalement et je vois mieux alors
vous ne pouvez pas pourquoi vous aviez
bien dans ma salle de somme alors
combien robert rosen directeur d'acteurs
méthyle à robert hossein acteurs de me
voir moi même parce que vous voyez on
imagine toujours qu'on n'a pas l'âge
parce que à l'intérieur on n'a pas là je
connais mal âge de mamou
alors dites moi vous parliez tout à
l'heure de l'enfer c'est les autres
vous trouvez ça toujours actuelle en
même temps moi je vous ai souvent
entendu parler de votre côté cela du
mythique l'homme qui croit en dieu qui
croient aux hommes comment vous
concilier cet amour de dieu et des
hommes et puis c'est ce message très
sombre de sartre finalement j'ai
d'ailleurs joué fois avec vous se posent
un regard sur les hommes sur mon
prochain sur leurs conditions très très
difficile aujourd'hui sous les milliers
d' injustice et sombre où je jouais moi
je vous jure que sans voix quand il
charge
je suis très préoccupé par le devenir de
la condition des hommes aujourd'hui nous
il est plus préoccupé aujourd'hui qu'il
ya quelques années vous êtes plus
pessimistes qu'il ya quelques années
c'est dans ce sens que la patine maman
vous croyez en quelque chose c'est à
dire en dieu mais moi je crois en dieu
parce que je peux voir les hommes qui
n'était pas le cas de sartre d'ailleurs
qui n'ont pas du tout mais ça c'était
d'une lucidité il était même visionnaire
et de la preuve c'est que cette pièce
est complètement intemporel et je vais
tout à fait deux fois avec vous moi je
passe ma journée à essayer d'exister de
tenter et pose fatalement mon regard sur
les problèmes des autres c'est
obligatoire si vous avez une conscience
mais alors je passe en enfer le soit
mais j'y passe qu'une ricaner en vain le
reste de la journée j'ai le temps
d'aller autre part qu'on en fait l'enfer
pour robert fait mais c'est quoi
c'est en ce moment c'est à ce moment
j'ai l'impression que je vais vous avez
chose terrible et je me serais je vous
jure que c'est pas désespérée puisque je
vous répète que je crois beaucoup de
choses je crois du résultat d'un réseau
j'ai l'impression que les hommes et
meurt un peu d'un monde
considération j'ai l'impression que
toutes les technologies tout ce qui
était d'améliorer leurs conditions
étaient trop de les asservir
j'ai l'impression su que l'injustice et
que le mot partage paraît complètement
abstrait et ensuite il nous faudrait
quelques visionnaires
parce que visionnaire c'est quand même
synonyme d'expérience oh je suis navré
de le constater nous avons beaucoup de
gestionnaires et c'est assez ga mesure
personne n'est plus du tout et tout le
monde vous un regard est interrogé on
est mal embarqué et c'est bien dommage
parce que de la vie c'est quand même une
histoire d'amour et ça pourrait quand
même et extraordinaire surtout une prise
de conscience un peu universel vous
espérez cette prise de conscience par
exemple les gens qui vont venir voir
huis clos à est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut dans un message comme ça qui est
assez sombre et lucide sur la condition
humaine est ce qu'on peut réaliser
comment je vous dire une chose parce que
dans danse art il est terrifiant il
dénonce un peu les choses et il nous met
en face de nous mêmes comme devant un
miroir avec nos faiblesses nos
contradictions saba mais tout à coup le
public de la manière dont on l'a monté
nos se regardent et se voit et voit
absolument par tous les états dans
lesquels il passe lui même par rapport à
cette situation infernale qui est de
fait de rester pour l'éternité à
s'affronter alors qu'on voudrait essayer
vraiment s'en sortir et j'ai
l'impression que les gens ce qu on sait
les interpeller ils sont complètement
concerné